it's an all-out battle between two men
who are icons of stalwart cinema and
bastions of bad movies Nicolas Cage
versus John Travolta both have had
legendary careers that spans decades and
their films run the gamut from the
greatest stories ever put on celluloid
to the most confusingly idiotic excuses
for a paycheck
both are deserving of our respect the
only one will be crowned the all-time
breadbox champion I bet Bruce Willis got
so mad here's how it worked
round 1 box office round 2 tomato meter
round 3 versatility and then we'll do a
wild-card round to help me stall until I
can come up with a winner tough
decisions make folks pull their hair out
but for me to declare a winner between
these two I might just have to take my
face oh this face oh you know 100 years
from now I hope people remember that
movie put that the time capsule as an
accurate representation of life in 1997
people were swapping faces all over the
place okay y'all ready let's get it on
round one box ah poor Nick and John were
prominent direct-to-dvd daddies they
made movies that were actually released
in theaters since John first graduated
from mr. Kotter sweathog class in the
mid-1970s his films have gone on to
gross a combined four point nine billion
dollars domestically and eight point two
three billion worldwide in honor of the
boy in the bubble I adjusted for
inflation early hits like Saturday Night
Fever and grease helped John keep a
healthy 201 million dollar per movie
average throughout his career all right
Nick time to see if you can match up
with greased lightning you turn me on
and Nick actually surpasses Danny Zuko
in terms of movies made so for films we
have box-office data for Nick leads 58
to 41 however he still trails in terms
of total domestic gross nick has 4.1
billion dollars and worldwide total 8.2
to billion dollars which according to my
ti 82
means his movies on average gross less
than John's but it's worth mentioning
that both have had huge runs in their
career where they were arguably the most
bankable movie star on the planet after
coming on the scene primarily with wacky
comedies and dark Indies Nic Cage became
everyone's favorite action star in the
mid-90s
look at films like Conair face off and
gone in 60 seconds all launched thanks
to his performance in the rock ironic
because Stanley Goodspeed wants no part
of any action of that movie that's the
film that empowered Michael Bay as I
mentioned John Travolta had a huge
arrival onto the big screen with some
impressive singing and dancing
afterwards he became the comeback kid
every time you doubted whether he could
be a relevant box office presence again
he'd answer with films like look who's
talking or pulp fiction I'd still pay
money to see a sequel to The Rock but if
we're talking overall box office John
Travolta is getting the nod he goes up
1-nothing let's just get this over with
John and Nic have made some bad bad
Rotten movies when you deal in the
business of death saving a life
can be the most deadly job of all we've
had lots of hearty guffaws at the
expensive cage but Travolta seems
particularly allergic to nightshades
did you know he's made seven movies
seven there are zero percent on the
tomato meter how is that even possible
if you tried could you replicate that
it's such incompetence to the level that
I'm almost impressed and I don't like
your attitude one bit Nic Cage has had
more than his share of duds as well and
a couple have even joined John it's zero
percent on the tomato meter maybe I
shouldn't breathe so much Terry huh
here's a fun game I'm gonna rattle off a
bunch of films and you tell me which one
is not a cage er Travolta disaster but
actually a movie I made when I was in
third grade
deadfall Grand Isle life on the line
speed kills
the poison rose and left behind give up
those are actually all Nic Cage or John
Travolta movies
I would never lump my crown jewel The
Legend of dark Cove in with that trash
there's a reason why we as a society
keep letting John and Nic make bad
movies it's because they've also made
some really great flicks Nic Cage
recently scored his highest ranked
filming that tomato meter ever with 2018
spider-man into the spider verse
currently 97% this is purple now he also
starred in Red Rock West at 95 percent
and moonstruck is at 93 percent
meanwhile Travolta's highest climb is
face off with Nick Cage and pulp fiction
both at 92 percent and despite making
more movies than John Nick retains a
higher per film average on the tomato
meter at 47 percent John weighed down by
his crowded gaggle of crap at 0% has a
40% average so if you need one last
piece of evidence and Nic Cage should
win this round how about this cages
loose prison trilogy off the rock con
air and face off average is 71 percent
while Travolta's bad guys smoking
quadrilogy of Broken Arrow face off
swordfish and The Punisher is only 58%
now you may claim that's totally
arbitrary and not fair but I had to do
it as a reminder
everyone how poorly 2004 is the Punisher
has aged oh he bring back Dolph Lundgren
Nic Cage gets the win and were tied at 1
2 1
he may have my song he doesn't have my
spirit both fellows have stuck around as
long as they have because they are
constantly able to reinvent themselves
all while maintaining some semblance of
the original persona that we fell in
love with sure John Travolta's Vincent
Vega bears little resemblance to Tony
Manero but he still gets out of the
dance floor and for that matter so does
Edna Turnblad in Hairspray
3 very different characters but all
distinctly Travolta I mean it wasn't me
Nicolas Cage may never be considered as
cool as John was in the 1970s but maybe
that's why he's able to be even more of
an on-screen chameleon he's a veritable
cartoon in Raising Arizona likeable
everyman in the rock what do you see we
cut the chitchat a whole and amazing
it's Charlie Kaufman in adaptation where
as Travolta we can prepare somewhat for
the type of character we're gonna get
Nic Cage
that's anyone's guess I don't even think
he knows both gentlemen can play the
hero or the antagonist Wow
we've got something in common the Nick
Cage more consistently challenges
himself and the audience and maybe
that's why he continues to turn out
quality films as diverse as Mandy Jo and
spider-verse big props to John Travolta
for being able to play cool
not everyone can and some of us struggle
with that in real life occasionally he
gets to go against type shout out to his
award-winning TV roles Robert Shapiro
and he can dance the night away but Nic
Cage is the more versatile performer he
wins the round and is up to the one on
Turo that's Travolta's character in
Battlefield Earth here's a pamphlet
check it out
- Rochester mega riot most iconic Nic
Cage John Travolta asking who's more
iconic is like asking who's more out of
their mind can't we just be happy that
they're both on Mars well however one
can achieve icon status chances are
these guys have done it Nic Cage is a
consistently great gift meme dinosaur
bone collector what have you and John
Travolta will not rest until he screws
up at Deana Menzel's named every way
possible see I can do it why can't he
does he so let's look at their most
noteworthy on-screen accomplishments
Nick takes the early lead because he's
won an Academy Award for leading Las
Vegas but more so than that film and yes
it is my most played Sheryl Crow song we
know Nick for going full-tilt and flicks
like The Wicker Man
kick-ass and of course vampires kiss if
you think you haven't seen vampires just
trust me you have he's a maniacally fun
guy to root for in national treasure
movies hairbrained 90's action films or
really deep art pieces that have been
drinking heavily just a nip but john
travolta at multiple times in his career
could be considered the coolest movie
star on the planet it doesn't matter if
he's Danny Zuko dreaming of summer lovin
in 1978 or chili Palmer trying to get
Napoleon greenlit almost twenty years
later there's no doubt the Nic Cage just
had a much better decade than John but
can you ever count out a guy who's made
at least five career comebacks in his
life
the
dude made wild hogs and he still gets
invited to the Oscars if that ain't
tough want I don't know what is could
the history of movies be written without
moonstruck leaving Las Vegas the rock or
adaptation I wouldn't like it but it
could on the other side of the coin I
don't think you can write a biography of
the talking pictures without gaudy I'm
kidding instead I'll say pulp fiction or
Saturday Night Fever Nicolas Cage has
become iconic for being Nic Cage but
John Travolta is an icon because he's a
movie star and he flops names Adel Nazim
really and he just kept smiling I was my
favorite part
John you win the round our hearts and
we're all tied up at two what and now I
have to make possibly the toughest
decision of my young career who wins
Nicolas Cage or John Travolta and my
answer is that before we get to that
there's another justice fun question who
was better and face off it's impossible
to tell Cage takes the early lead as the
villainous pastor Troy but then they do
the face whap and suddenly Travolta gets
to have all the fun including a super
creepy scene with his own daughter I
mean I know that's not really his
daughter but he thing's dead so the
damage has been done
and then there's an epic fight scene and
we get to completely reverse the surgery
how did we use an audience by that in
1997 these guys swap faces twice and the
recovery time is less than lazing I
think it's a dead heat but if I have to
pick one I'm going with cage and face
off because I'm going with John Travolta
overall
ruch john travolta narrowly edges out
Nick Cade because in a hundred years
from now when the Face Swap technology
actually exists we will still be talking
about how great Saturday Night Fever
increase was and what an impact old
fiction had on the art of cinema if it's
any consolation all you Nick Cage fans
out there recently a national treasure
tree was Greenland it's about damn time
now we just need an a-list villain to
race against Nick for a priceless
artifact hmm I think I know someone and
now it's time for you the dear viewer to
get involved comment below with your
vote is it team Nick or is it team John
let us know and defend your answer until
next time I'm Mark Ellis reminding you
to stop breaking arrows and start
striking the moon I probably should have
gone with raising Arizona have a good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]